υποθέση με το χάκο ο εκδοθίλες τη εμερκή αυτός ήταν αν και ήταν σενε αρύ
πολύ είναιαριδηλικία αυτός ναι έκανε είναιαρκετάμεγάλες ζημίες κ όχι μόνο στη κύπρο αλλά και το
εξιωτερικό γι αυτό τον λόγον έχει η εκδοθείκαι στς είπα γιαμεγαλη αυτή δηπόθεση και καταδικάαυτηκαι
να στασιάδι επιδή βλέπουμα καθημερινά τράπεζι κι τράπεζες με να πέφτουν θύματα αυτό τον άτομα
που έχουν λογαριασμός ου σιαστικά να πεφτουν θύματα αυτόν το χάκς δημόσιες υπηρεσίες με ημέλ
και όχι μόνο πλέον όλοι αυτή δημόσια επηρεσία διατικός το μέας είναι θορακισμένοι ώστε να
αποτρέψουν τέτοιες επιθέσεις να πω ότι εκατότες εκατό κανένας δεν μπορεί ναι εναι σίγουρος να
έχουμε νυπόψειμασ ότι το λάθος μπορεί να συμβεί από τιοχειρισμόν κάποιου ίμι ηλανθέλετε από κάποιον
υπάλληλο λαδεί ένας λειτουργός μιας δημόσιας υπεριθέσει μιας τράπε α δενός οργανισμού ανεξενάεμέν μπορείνα αντιξενανή
μιλ να πατήσει των ηλεκτρονικό σύνδεθμον και να υπάρξει ο λάθος υπάρχει και γι αρχή
ψυρσια και ς ασφάλειας οι οποίια κάνει πολύ καλή δουλειά ανκενεμοσύστατη κάνει και πολύ καλή
δουλιάν έχει προειδοποιήσει όλος τους οργανισμούς έχουμε και εμείσ ανστημεμίες υνεσφέρεις σε αυτόν το τομέα
προσπαθούμε να αντημερώςσεο εντοκοινών και τις επιχειρήσεις και τους οργανισμούς γιατιχών επιθέσεις αφήμα θυμάύτει της
το κτηματο λόγιο των εκτώπανηνής στήμιον το γανημστημών κύπρου με τις επιθέσεις που είχαν και
ουτο καθεξείς δεν κανένας δεν μπορεί να πει ότι είναι σίγουρος εκατόνες εκατόν γιατί γιατί
δεν συνμβερν αυτά τα πράγματα μόνο στην κύπρονα συμβαίνουν και σε πολύ μεγάλους οργανιμοσους προ
ξέρουμε ίνα εμείς σε πάρα πολύ μεγάλος οργανισμούςσεις το εξιωτερικόν τράπεζες έχουν μεγάλης εμπελείας παγκόσμιας
εμβελίας έχουν πραβιαστεί